[Music]
and uber to the rescue news submitted by
skrt skrt skrt an uber driver stepped in
as a friend after a passenger was
abandoned by her boy hmm
it was during Serge place hours that's a
truly noble thing because they make Bank
on that [ __ ] dude
this story is about this girl and this
girl so this is the uber driver Vicky
and this is the passenger named Lea Lea
bass like Anthony's bi-able yeah but it
spelled the white girl way l eh LOL eh
eh here the story begins i was driving
for uber today and this girl gets in the
car I asked her how was her day been and
she breaks down Shh oh damn that's like
me to Nikki oh my hey honey how you
doing then she breaks down my oh [ __ ]
why did I ask the next hour my life is
[ __ ]
thank you I'm like when I can't keep
playing grandpa's auto or can I know I
can't should I have asked at 10 but
that's why they have headsets you need
the peg life like it's unclad what's the
fault this is my whole t-shirt yeah she
continues she tells me that she flew
alone from Texas to see a guy and he
abandoned her so I did what I would want
someone to do for me I invited her to
hang out with my friends and I like
y'all don't understand this girl was
near her breaking point
she thought she could trust this guy
she's been alone at her hotel since
Thursday my friends and I are about to
show her a bomb time so that her trip
isn't completely what a nice lady yes
hope she can deliver though and that's a
lot of pressures they weren't show you a
bomb time Sunday Bible so I was like no
no Kate huh I know right the next week
says update my friends and I offered to
jump the guy for her but she politely
declined but and so that karma will get
him like this karma might get him but my
hands are faster
my god that's adult yeah I'm gonna [ __ ]
him up for you next week she just told
us that when he came to her hotel he
asked her where he could park his car so
no one would see it please she has a car
he claims since he plays for FSU his
coach would be mad if he knew he was
there like I'm pissed
he clearly hiding something what do
y'all think yes bring it on love that we
would I mean he could've just took her
over if he was that I know right I know
what the hell if he's broke - he's a
broke loser
next one update her name is Leia she's
super sweet and charming and I'm about
to show her a good time taking her to a
pregame already got her listening to
Florida music like iceberg and major
nine changing her life and getting yeah
they're both very attractive Yeah right
it's like you could have had an orgy
totally miss no charges this guy's like
she's a 9.5 not good enough the button
yeah she does she does have a little bit
of the the Affleck but ginger reason
treating these people think they should
so pretty what enemies people like
buttons that's why they love pretty
enemies people like dimples be fat no
tooth and the button the what tooths the
snaggletooth know about this one because
like that the loose tooth yeah the
Japanese somebody likes his navel do I
[Music]
say she's stage-dive I have no word this
has become a responsibility greater than
I could have ever imagined she's
heartbroken her emotions are everywhere
and the alcohol has enhanced that I
don't regret it at least she's having
fun
casteau update i'm i eat ur [ __ ] you
don't mean like that's where this is
slowly going
kind of dating a pill dissolved exactly
how I thought it would oh no I know you
know I have to ship them everything
fanservice it's a fanservice right hater
fuzzy yeah sometimes you got to help a
girl out right and then it's like a
picture of like a smiling Martha Stewart
holding a pie or some [ __ ] like a
half-eaten pie that's the euphemism cuz
she's been doing that for everyone yeah
I got it kill me is that [ __ ] eating
emoji this should be person space that
whole thing like that cat oh yeah that's
pretty good but you see that vagina
that's what the cat cats have vaginas
yeah this is fur
it's part covered by said vaginas
something I've worked a lot of cases
I've seen a lot of Kitty MacGyver her
next week it says update his name is and
then they cross it out she's standing
outside the club I tried to tell her not
to call based on every excuse he's used
to avoid her he either has a girlfriend
or is a sociopath he literally told her
I gotta leave because I need to put
lotion on my face what in the live
footage okay he's a model he's terrible
at this absolutely she's the worst
cheater lotion gotta go right it's the
best thing in Kabul I know oh [ __ ] next
week update he tried his lies on me but
I hit him with the receipts talking
about he can't be around her because
he's a student athlete I said how does
that matter when you didn't even get in
the game the season oh she did some
research on here good student athlete
she's like like please give a better
excuse and then there's like a video
we're like talking damn I love it we
were not the best detectives when
they're angry hmm if you have that smart
Hong what happened to this girl man
no the girl who's helping because
something happened to her - she's like
getting revenge on like multiple angles
right now
right it's just being a female yeah you
know that that Mama Bear instinct that
mom to have with their kids it's the
same as applied with people you love
it's like you didn't know you were
detective until you put it your friends
put into that corner and you're like
[ __ ] that yeah but it's always got to be
that friend because the one that's in
love she's black mm-hmm that friend guys
don't have that guys are like oh she's
going to Palms good luck buddy
like every guy I've ever dated like oh
yeah like I haven't autumn like uh-huh
yeah the one that lives in Tennessee I
know you know like I know everything
about you right that's true Nikki knows
all that [ __ ] I don't I don't even know
her cousin's name like her sister better
than names that be wet I don't know her
sister's name I mean she's an only child
yeah no no a but I don't know a lot of
the names is crazy
and because they're all like Filipino I
just it's like a goddamn nightmare
because everyone well the guys are all
for example the guys are all named
Benjamin and you can't remember their
that's the easy part
okay and the women I'm like forget it oh
yeah that tickles and [ __ ] there's some
people that she likes you can with cholo
know it's like a nickname besides like I
know aunt Tita because that sounds like
a I don't know sounds like that means
that oh really
yeah it means aunt or does it mean big
sister no I means big sister
no Tita the oldest PETA and people so
people like PETA Jenn that's gold pitas
auntie Oh and then sisters opting and
adding and what's PETA because ice
boobies no you beat that aunt dete those
up there is sister older stuff yeah yeah
so you just send all their names so you
know them better than I do
well means it's like even like every
single Filipino family has at least one
Pete the baby it's like a nickname
that's my sister's girls are just go at
details I know that means you can't get
anything past this next rule and she
says update I just told him to watch his
back because I was going to tell my
Twitter fam his at anyone know this
prayer he claims to be a student athlete
for Florida State so good that he thinks
he can treat girls however he wants to
help without it backfiring
how many followers she had it doesn't
matter because I mean Twitter gets ahold
of it it feels crazy when it's not to
retweet it
[Music]
I really I love this I love her oh look
at her it's hereditary choice so Dan
what hapa update she's family back at
her at her hotel I have to take all my
other friends homes oh I thought she was
gonna take off all her clothes is
constantly turning into a lesbian porn
that's what sounds very she's very
involved yeah variable that's Joplin's
oh no she has 32 point 4 K followers by
the way that's a good amount I have to
take all my friend my other friends home
but I promise to check on her in the
morning and drive her to the airport to
catch her flight the night was wild but
it was worth it glad to have met my new
friend Leia part that's a bird driver I
will give her five stars I give her four
and a half stars I'm pretty good with
her with Leia yeah oh and then there's
like a towel wrapped in her hair okay
that's a girlfriend right there like
that's a good girlfriend last one she's
on her way home Texas take care of her
hmm photos I showed you in the beginning
oh she came from Texas that's dogs to
Florida right yeah really nice she just
became extra pretty to me yeah really
just like that well that's how it works
with everyone guys or girls if the guys
like not that attractive and then he's
really really sweet and I'm like God Ana
you're very attractive I've never
thought of that
all right girls are [ __ ] [ __ ] and
they're [ __ ] gorgeous but they're a
[ __ ] I'm like you are ugly piece of
oops immediately yeah yeah yeah it's
like that once where we did with the
girl who had the number huh remember we
did that story with the girl got a
double arm or whatever she'd like one
arm or some [ __ ] oh man she went in on
vaycay and she was super attractive I
know that she just twisted those and I
was like no she did she was like sweet
again everybody she lived she lived it
yeah she I don't know how she was like
that we suck ya know cuz I think we said
like 95% positive things but 5% kind of
jokingly things always but it's like we
were just repeating the same jokes that
you set on yourself right he now now
that she did that oh she's ugly she's
ugly there you go very attractive
cuz she had a dope sense of humor but
now she doesn't have a thought
but you're gonna think of the other no I
wasn't yeah why that's that's true but
now I went the other way see see how
pretty that happens she's exactly right
that's true though not like we yes go
from supporting her it's you like [ __ ]
you and your one arm especially your one
arm
[Music]